Oo.
Ang quantum circuit ang magiging unit ng halaga
para sa iyong negosyo — ang qubit ang unit ng impormasyon
pero ang circuit ang unit ng computation
kaya subukan nating intindihin kung ano ang quantum circuit
at tingnan natin ang anatomy nito
ganito ang hitsura ng isang quantum circuit —
binubuo ito ng mga piraso: ang mga qubit
ay kinakatawan ng mga pahalang na linya — dito ipinapakita natin
ang isang circuit na may apat na qubit na makikita mo
dito — ngayon ang mga gate ay
kung paano natin kontrolin ang mga qubit
at binabasa ang mga gate mula kaliwa pakanan
at ang single-qubit gate ay maaaring single-
qubit gate o multi-qubit gate
makikita mo doon ang controlled gate —
yung may linya sa pagitan ng dalawang qubit
at doon mangyayari ang entangling operation
at sa huli mayroon kang measurement at classical output
at napakahalaga — maraming beses mong pinapatakbo ang isang circuit
para makuha ang resulta gamit ang konsepto ng shots
kaya ang shot count ay ang bilang ng beses
na kailangang ulitin ang computation para makuha ang resulta
okay
ano ba ang hitsura nila
tingnan natin kung ano ang hitsura ng two-qubit —
yun yung larawan kanina — nagpapakilala ng phase change
at ipinakita ko kanina ang isang operasyon na gumagawa ng rotation na iyon
na nagpapahintulot sa interference operation na mangyari
kaya ikumpara natin ang classical circuit
at ang quantum circuit — sa classical circuit makikita mo
na wala kang makikitang blue moons dito
walang mga rotation — lahat dito ay pink
at makukuha mo ang single states
na sa mga gate na ito ay nakikita mo ang isang tiyak na larawan
pero pansinin kung gaano kaiba ang magiging hitsura
kapag talaga nating ipinatupad ang isang quantum circuit
ito ang mga aktwal na circuit na pinapatakbo natin sa ating mga quantum computer
na maaari mo ring subukan
ang mga circuit na ating lilikha
sa pamamagitan ng kombinasyon ng mga gate
ay bumubuo ng buong kumplikadong amplitude
na larawan na ibinahagi ko sa inyo
kanina — bakit iyon mahalaga
dahil kaya na nating buuin ang mga kumplikadong relasyon na ito
sa pagitan ng mga qubit sa mga tuntunin ng mga phase
at entanglement at saka sa pamamagitan ng measurement
kaya nating i-collapse ang napakalaking halaga
ng computation na nagaganap sa loob patungo sa
isang mahalagang sagot
at ganoon natin sa wakas naaabot
ang sagot — kaya kapag inilagay natin sila nang magkatabi biswal lang
mararamdaman mo na ang classical circuit ay hindi kailanman
makakasamantala sa napakalawak na computational space
na kaya ng quantum circuit —
ito ang nagbibigay sa iyo ng intuisyon
ng kayamanan ng paraan ng pag-access natin sa malaking state na ito.
At ang magandang parte nito ay kaya nating
magkaroon ng maraming klase ng circuit para
sa iba't ibang function — kaya
halimbawa ito ay isang circuit
na dinisenyo para mag-model ng financial risk
narito ang isang halimbawa ng circuit
na ginagamit para sa paghahanap at pag-optimize ng mga problema
at narito ang isang halimbawa ng circuit na ginagamit para
mag-simulate ng molecule — isang mahalagang
punto dito ay maaari kang mag-disenyo ng iba't ibang circuit
para sa iba't ibang aplikasyon
ang mga circuit na ating dinisenyo ay kinukuha
sa software at iniingatan bilang software
at sa aming kaso iniingatan namin ang mga ito sa Qiskit
na aming open source development kit para sa quantum computing
ito ay isa sa pinakamalawak na ginagamit na
software framework para sa quantum computing
at maiisip mo na magtayo ng
mga library ng mga circuit na naka-embed sa
mga classical program na pinagsama-sama na ngayon ang pinakamahusay ng classical programming
at ang pinakamahusay ng kapangyarihan ng quantum